for more on what a potential default
could mean for you there at home let's
bring in CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger Jill good morning if an
agreement is not reached by June 1st
what happens let's just calendar on June
1st we have a series of payments that
we're due to make and remember for every
dollar that comes that of spending we
have to do we only get about 75 cents of
Revenue so on June 1st Medicare
providers are due 47 billion dollars
veterans benefits military pay and
retirement civil service retirement
billions of dollars here the following
day June 2nd 67 million Americans
receive Social Security 25 billion
dollars due so who's paying that money
and what are people to do who are not
getting that money so that let's take
that question of what are people to do
if you're a military family if you're a
retiree and that money could be held up
early June how do you prepare you know
at this point I don't think there's a
ton to do this is why you have an
emergency Reserve fund it's interesting
on my podcast I was hearing from a lot
of military families who said what
should we do in advance and I said
stockpiled cash it's probably not going
to last too long if we do hit that
breaching moment but for a week or two
you really do need to fall back on
emergency savings if you don't have it
take a deep breath this will get
corrected quickly I promise okay the
stock market so far seems to be holding
is it going to hold I mean as we get
closer we really are worried about the
volatility in the marketplace go back to
2011. remember we dropped 14 over four
weeks when we got really close and that
was because s p downgraded the debt but
so far this year the stock market has
come back pretty strong hang on it's
going to be a very bumpy ride for the
next time putting my seat belt on thank
you very much Joe appreciate it thank
you